i remember when i was go-go-dancing one
night and this guy came up to me he's
like
i'm like hey what's up he goes um i just
want to let you know one of your lips is
hanging out
[Music]
hello welcome back to big mood we have
some beautiful ladies here but most of
all most important one
me
we got julia
yeah so happy to have you
happy thank you so much i know i miss
you guys too like literally the whole
entire quarantine i'm like where are my
friends yeah
so who else do we have here jess of
course of course oh hi it's gina yeah
and tiff the most important one in the
room
but yeah so today we're going to be
talking about uh subtle signs
that someone is actually a really good
person so you know but a bad red flag
like red flags for bad people are really
apparent
you can easily tell when someone has
like a bad character
or whatever it is like when they treat
for example when they treat service
workers poorly
um or whatever like you immediately know
like oh this person is kind of shitty
but no one really talks about good like
like we kind of look over when someone
may actually really be a good person
like maybe their attitude doesn't first
like let you know like is this a good
person or not but then they do other
things and you're like oh wait those are
actual signs of a good person regardless
of their [ __ ] attitude are green
flags a thing i think
this is a green flag for a guy or this
is a yellow be careful
what would a yellow flag be something
that i don't know like
i don't know like something that's not
super bad but you got to kind of wait
and watch it doesn't put the shopping
cart back that's a
yeah is this person selfish or is that
you know like what's the response we got
we needed more time to suss it out i
think that's a yellow flag that makes
sense
julia off the top of your head what do
you think could be a a
good green flag that someone's a good
person
oh uh
hmm
[Music]
uh i i think like allowing
yo that charges move by itself
casey thought i knew the cat was serious
i was like he's like why are you so calm
about this
are you serious right now in the
spiritual ass house okay i didn't
realize the cat was here no i can't i
jumped off a chair
the chair and they were using it as a
scratching post and then jumped off i
just nearly shut myself i didn't
understand why everyone was so calm okay
sorry we probably need to call and nicky
be like can you just like uh burn a sage
like just purify it not needed it was a
cat it's okay
okay so julia was about to say yeah
green flag um i think
allowing someone who's quiet to speak oh
my god that's literally the first one oh
really yes oh so
the way they specifically wrote this was
they make space for someone who is being
ignored in a conversation
we gotta elaborate um
i don't know i just
like for anybody that's like quiet in
the room i'd be like what do you think
they're like oh what i'm like what do
you think come on say something and
they're like i don't know i'm like
that's fine you don't have to see
anything you don't want to but i think
it's just like
i like when i feel that someone is quiet
but they have something they want to say
like i want to be sure that they get
heard
yeah so that's how that's how i kind of
feel but like i know that there are
people that just genuinely want to stay
quiet and don't even want to say
anything i'm like that's fine that works
too oh yeah that energy thing i hate
that feeling so i noticed when people do
this now so i try to stop it but when
someone's talking and then you just
realize that everyone else is ignoring
them
and they're telling a story i make it a
point to like yes what yeah go ahead
yeah you know like what are you saying
i'm listening or sometimes it'll be a
joke yeah yeah yeah i feel like it does
that girl i know that i don't let people
do that to me because i'll be like yeah
and i was telling a story so you need to
go ahead and
come back over here
like i want to make sure
if people stop listening i'll throw a
fit so yeah dude i give up i'm just like
yeah well i i mean if i get pissed off
enough yeah and it's happened like so
much for years
but for the most part though
for the most part like in a regular
setting yeah i'll just be like yeah so
i'm saying this and i'm talking over
here listening and then okay
but like that is like such a signature
sound right because like you start out
loud and then as you're saying your
story you were like oh yeah and then oh
yeah like that happened and yeah but
everyone's still talking over here and i
was listening to yeah
yeah yeah yeah either i'll troll off or
i'll stop talking i'll be like okay
never mind yeah
usually though like i because i i hear
you do that you've done it multiple
times in our lives where you travel as
soon as i hear that and no one's
listening and i i perk back up and i'm
like tiff i was listening
i do it
she needs attention i don't know you
paid attention
so this person wrote uh they said you
know when you're in a group that only
one person and and that one person keeps
trying to say something but they keep
getting talked over
look for the person that will stop and
say sorry your name i didn't catch what
you were trying to say can you repeat it
or something like that and make space
for the person being ignored
unintentionally that's a great gem i
mean a real gem yeah i love people like
that i think um it's especially hard too
being in a
some in a place like la where everyone
has to be like the big the loudest the
you know the most interesting or
whatever so a lot of times people don't
even really care what anyone else around
them is saying they just have to
be their person too and and if you can
find a group or a person in a group that
is like that that will stop
then you know they have to
care you know what i mean and it feels
good because i've been in situations
like that and i think even um
david even though we're not super close
i do remember a few times where i just
felt like very invisible when i would
first come into the group and he would
he would kind of notice that and then
like make it a point to make me feel
seen so
i mean
yeah i just i
felt someone do that for me before too
so i think that's it's helpful and it's
very nice when someone will do that yeah
makes you feel like oh yeah like someone
does care yeah
or like i'm not totally [ __ ]
invisible jesus yeah that's true sorry
jess where you say something
yeah you know what i kind of um notice
about myself though i think because i
got so used to
having to fight for my like for the
attention
because for so many years i was always
like a quiet little mouse and i'm just
like that's okay fine all right whatever
i'll be ignored but then i'm like wait
but no that feels shitty like and it
feels good to actually have the
attention like to grab the attention and
people are actually listening to what
i'm saying so then i notice now that i
unintentionally will talk over people so
i'm like oh [ __ ] and then i catch myself
and i'm like [ __ ] i gotta stop cause now
i'm doing it to others when i'm not
trying to
and then um so that's like a little like
um what is the word
over correction oh what is it pet pet
peeve or whatever about myself where i'm
like oh you feel like you do it too much
now like i feel like sometimes i'll oh
it's because then i'll get excited about
whatever we're talking and then i'm like
oh yeah and then i want to put in like
my two cents but then i realized like oh
[ __ ] i cut someone off when they were
saying so then i'll try to make it a
point to be like i'm so sorry what were
you saying yeah i'm like oh yeah i think
when it's done to me right i just did it
no no no it's fine i think like there's
there's always there's always a place
for a balance right because i think even
though you don't have any intention to
cut somebody off you still at least give
them the chance to finish whatever they
wanted to say if i catch it if you catch
it but i mean i feel like
from going from like you know like you
feeling like as if you were like mousy
or just like not saying anything to
actually being able to like state what
you want to say i think that's still an
improvement it's just it's just a
balance i would just say don't go too
far extreme but i don't think you do i
think you're really pretty good about it
yeah i think it's okay because even if
you interrupt people and talk over them
or whatever there's still space in the
conversation like you won't just
steamroll them to the point where they
never get anything yeah there's people
like that yeah like they're or they're
just in a group someone that will be
completely just outcasted the whole time
like
i don't think any of us really would
allow someone for the entire time we're
around them for them to feel completely
ignored like that's really shitty that's
true
we're good people
unbiased opinion we are
perfect
all right the next one here it says
um when they're willing to stand up to
people being rude to service workers
yeah
it says i was at a family dinner at a
pub years ago and my sister was very
rude to the waiter because her steak was
overcooked or something she really went
hard on him and my brother's new
girlfriend who always seemed a shy and
quiet person told my sister to basically
stop being a [ __ ] and that waiters
didn't cook the food and that she's
embarrassing all of us everyone's and
that everyone's looking at us and etc
from that point on i knew she was a i
knew she was the good sort yeah
you have to stand up for people that
can't
not that they can't but you know at work
they really can't do it yes they're not
in the right position to be able to snap
back or anything but you are as another
patron you are definitely in that
position and that's really ballsy too
because it was uh she's a new girlfriend
like me and the boyfriend's family yeah
like that's like really yeah she could
be instantly out casted from or like he
might have to break up with her if like
everyone hates her or something so she
didn't give a [ __ ] she was just like no
don't talk to him like that like that's
too much yeah i would like to think of
it as
for her like in her position it's like
well if i don't get along with these
people then this is a good sign yeah
really figure out their true nature so
like even if they don't like me good bad
y'all are okay with this behavior
because if so i'm out exactly i'm not
gonna have all these dinners like with
people treating people like [ __ ] all the
time like
yeah yeah i can't stand those there's
people i've met people who are like oh
because when i eat especially if you've
worked in service before um when i eat
after i'm done i kind of stack all my
plates and make it all nice and neat
yeah yeah and then i've gone out to eat
with people before they're like why are
you doing that that's their job i'm like
okay yeah it's their job but it doesn't
help to just or it doesn't hurt to help
someone a little bit you know do you do
it to help them though i do it for
myself because i don't like clutter
you're a good person you just take a
long route there
i don't like clutter so i like to like
clean up the table and sometimes they're
a little slow so you know i like to like
hurry up and get this [ __ ] out of my way
yeah i used to pick up the plates and
stuff and not that i ever well i did
have like a job briefly where i did that
but but um
i stopped doing it though because
there was a time where i forgot where i
was
what restaurant i was at but i remember
like the impact it had on me which was
the service people they were they were
offended that i was doing that for them
it depends on the country it depends the
level of restaurant and also if their
managers are watching because then you
make them look like they're not doing
that exactly and that's why i was like
oh [ __ ] okay i won't touch it like i
don't know i don't know what the [ __ ]
rules are and all these different
restaurants like i'm scared i don't want
to i would say the fancier it is the
less you're supposed to touch anything
like if you drop something on the floor
you're not even supposed to pick it up
which i find very strange yeah like if
you drop a knife or fork slides off the
table like you can't pick it up yo
that's like premium service right there
yeah
so definitely don't do it at a fancy
place yeah no no i know that for a fact
i never would have done it at a fancy
place but i guess it was like higher up
there yeah kind of like the middle
middle higher up at the restaurant yeah
like they came and they just like took
it with like kind of an attitude and i
was like [ __ ] actually kind of curious
now hey people in the comments
that work in food service let us know do
you like it when we do that or you don't
and i think type of establishment
i think also if you stack it in a way
that makes their job harder they don't
like it either so there's certain things
you can do that could create
damn like it could damage the
plates and silver and stuff so i mean if
you're a little bit cognizant of like
how you're stacking it too and like how
they have to carry it yeah i'd rather be
like on the side of like good intentions
even if i'm doing it wrong yeah as
opposed to well it's their job why are
you doing it for them like let them do
it you know right i feel like i mean
because i i used to bust tables before
and so
when um whenever i see like plates
stacked i'm like
because then i always feel weird having
to like reach across the table and be
like oh sorry excuse me let me just like
organize these plates but if they
already did it like it's much
appreciated uh by all pushes to the edge
of the table yeah yeah i also don't
expect them to do it either right yeah
but i mean especially for like all you
can eat places too yeah yeah
that's true yeah through a point
all right next one so they ask how
you're doing and actually mean it
they wrote i have this friend who i can
just tell is really sincere when he asks
how i'm doing i appreciate anyone asking
because it's a i appreciate anyone
asking because it's a convenient
conversation starter but with him i can
tell that he actually cares what the
answer is
i've met people like this too and you
definitely you definitely feel like
yeah genuine like authentic interest
from them is that a good person or is
that just someone you're close to
like i know whenever i have a
rule that if somebody asks me hey how
are you doing or what did you do today i
make it a point to ask back unless i'm
like really like i really don't want to
talk to you then i don't ask back
because i don't ever want to be that
person
i think i learned this because uh one of
my friends jokingly said
that's cool i had a good day too because
i didn't ask back yeah okay cool jean i
had a great day too and that's like oh
[ __ ] that's kind of rude so i make it a
point now to ask back unless it's like a
creepy guy then i'm like
i'm good sir
why are you asking yeah i don't know is
that a yeah i don't know i don't know if
that's a good person thing well because
i guess you know you could be close to
your friends and feel like they don't
care about you too i don't know i just
said why would you want
like if someone's not gonna care about
about you are you close to them um i
mean i think there's like a difference
like i think for that statement in
particular like if it's just anybody
whether a close friend or a co-worker if
they were to ask like hey how are you
doing it's like i think just feeding off
of that energy of how they deliver that
statement is whether it's like oh wow
like i can actually feel the care from
those words or not and it's just like
with my coworkers
i feel like
even though we just have a working
relationship for those i ask because
there is a difference like for those
that ask like oh yeah how are you doing
right it's just kind of like
pleasantries right be like oh yeah you
know i had like [ __ ] yeah i was like
oh i had a great weekend
and then there's some people they're
like
no but seriously like how how are you
doing you know and then like they kind
of like introduced like a more of like a
deeper kind of topic when you like talk
be like oh yeah you know um
this weekend like it was just quite a
roller coaster blah blah you know like
they kind of go into details about their
day i'm like okay so they really want to
know because they're now sharing a piece
of information with me so it's like okay
yeah i could feel that yeah yeah like
one of the times that stand out to me
when i did experience that was like
in the early
days of uh
knowing steve like we weren't close
we definitely weren't closed like we
weren't like you know like that but
somehow like steve can like
like
just open up the [ __ ] and like get
to your soul and not like [ __ ]
yeah so like when he would ask like i
really felt like i felt that he
genuinely cared and he really wanted to
know and he was invested in the
conversation and he would give us
feedback and like
that's the the type that's the type of
situation that comes to mind when i read
that because i'm like yeah i've
experienced that yeah definitely and it
definitely feels good and it feels like
like yeah like that person is a genuine
person they genuinely care and have love
to give you know what i mean
do you guys ever get annoyed when
someone asks how you are
um i don't but i do know people that do
because um most of the time they're not
feeling their best and so when you ask
them that they're like what do you mean
by that like it's just like it feels
like such an open question to you know
how to answer this negative yeah where
it's like what do you want do you want
the pleasant answer or do you want the
real truth like do you want to know like
oh yeah i'm fine i'm cool or do you want
to know like yeah i had a really [ __ ]
day and this is the reason why it's like
which one do you want yeah yeah that can
be tough do you feel like you get
annoyed um i think that sometimes i
don't know i feel like sometimes people
use that as filler for conversation and
it can get annoying to me
or i'm just like why do you ask that so
much
and it just seems like they're just
trying to like
i don't know there's there's like i
don't know there's times when i'm
definitely when someone's like well how
are you doing or how are you doing or
like that's the first thing and the only
like they constantly ask me well how are
you doing or how are you doing today how
are you doing i'm just like
the same every day is the same like what
do you want me to say like there's
nothing to talk about like why do you
keep asking me how i'm doing i think i
think them asking it was like come on
get a noise
tell them no
i think they want me to talk and like
share and stuff but sometimes i'm just
like
i don't have anything to share like i
don't have anything to say and it kind
of annoys me like
i don't know wait what if they meant it
as more like a light like oh hey how are
you doing no i'm good no it's just like
uh so how are you doing and i'm just
like i don't want to get into [ __ ] with
you right now like you know yeah i don't
know so i sometimes yeah i mean i get
that that's a good person or like maybe
they really care but sometimes i'm just
like god i stop [ __ ] asking me how
ask me something else like ask me how i
feel about politics ask me let's like
talk about something interesting [ __ ]
like stop asking me how are you doing
today oh tomorrow how are you doing
today like
oh my god this just sparked this just
sparked an encounter that i had with you
long me
yeah so i came into the new jk office
and i think we were getting ready to
prep for like jk news and it was like
really dark in the office and i was like
are you in here i was sitting in the
dark i don't know i don't know you you
were sitting in an office okay but i was
like out in the public space and then i
was like i heard like a shuffle and i
was like
someone here and then
you were like yeah i'm here
and i'll be like
jess are you are you okay
and then i just remember like a long
silence and then just being like
no oh
i was like oh
yeah that's cute yeah i don't think it's
so funny i was like do you want to talk
about it if not like i can just go about
the day you shoot jess was like
i don't know maybe sure
and then later i remember like tiff came
by and then we were all talking about
probably because i would want to talk to
you maybe i get annoyed because like i
just don't want to tell that person
stuff or something but yeah there's
definitely one person specifically where
i'm just like stop asking me how are you
doing
i get it it's the most annoying question
to me but i think it's maybe just the
person maybe it's like person place or
time i don't know i want to know who it
is just a picture it's not me because no
it's not you it's not anyone it's not
anyone in this room at all
all right so before we continue uh
we're gonna take a quick ad break and
make sure you
buy the stuff that we're talking about
buy some stuff
help support us
online shopping can be daunting you
never know if things will fit returns
are so hard and you don't know what
store to start with this season let's
stitch fix do all the hard work it makes
dressing so much easier for someone like
me who doesn't really like to put
outfits together i like it when someone
else does it for me i put it on it looks
great and i just go introducing stitch
fix freestyle a shop built just for you
stitch fix freestyle is your trusted
style destination where you can discover
and instantly buy curated items based on
your likes style and lifestyle whether
you're looking for a brand you love or
to try a new one at stitchfix freestyle
you can shop over a thousand brands
personalized to your size and fit with
styles for workouts to work where for
lounging around the house or for a night
out stitch fix freestyle has clothes for
any occasion plus there's no
subscription required and they offer
free shipping returns and exchanges get
started today by filling out your style
quiz at stitchfix.com big mood that's
stitchfix.com
bigmood to try stitch fix freestyle
again that's stitchfix.com
big mood cheers to 2022 and resolutions
you can actually keep how about having
clean and shiny balls all year round our
sponsors at manscaped are here to save
your balls this year and make the ball
drop into 2022 the cleanest and sexiest
ever this year take your package to the
next level with their performance
package 4.0 and brand new ultra premium
body wash inside the performance package
you'll find the signature lawnmower 4.0
which is the electric trimmer that's
designed to trim hair on loose skin with
its advanced skin safe technology they
also have anti-chafing ball deodorant
and a ball spray toner that takes care
of the smelliest parts of your body and
gives you a big boost to your confidence
in the new year to complete the set
they're also giving you free gifts
anti-chafing boxer briefs as well as the
travel bag to keep all your goodies
stored comfortably the new ultra premium
body wash from manscape is cologne
infused with aloe vera and sea salt to
help keeping your skin feeling clean
nice and moisturized kick discomfort and
pour hygiene to the curb this year and
use the best tools for the job get 20
off and free shipping with the code mood
at manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com and use code
mood it's a new year no pubes in 2022
with manscaped go to manscape.com and
use code mood all right and we're back i
hope you purchased some cool stuff
okay
so the next one says
when they crack jokes but never at
anybody else's expense
this guy i used to work with was such a
class clown always cracking jokes
everybody liked him because he was so
funny it was a while before i realized
that his jokes were never at anybody's
expense there was never anything mean
and anything he ever said to anybody's
face or behind their back guys are we
are we bad people
we crack jokes and other people's
expense
each other's expenses yeah are we bad
i don't know well in a working situation
right like you don't you don't you want
to toe the line with everyone because
you're not really friends with them like
that but i think we are friends like
that so we can talk [ __ ] to each other
sometimes we get a little heated
especially me and nikki because we're
both like a bull
but then at the end of the day we're
like yeah we're just [ __ ] kidding but
it depends on your relationship with
those people i guess yeah definitely
usually when i crack jokes at people's
expense most of the time i do
accidentally yeah
and then i don't realize that what i
said was bad yeah whatever until
everyone else reacts i was like oh [ __ ]
sorry
that's funny but yeah i mean obviously i
think it's a good sign um when someone's
cognizant of everyone's feelings when
you don't even realize that they're like
probably actively thinking about other
people's feelings because to be a good
person it does require some sort of
effort to care about the people around
you yeah
it can be can be hard for some of us
it's a challenge
what do you think julia i mean i don't
really
personally for me i don't think i could
ever really deliver jokes per se or
intentionally create jokes just because
like oh yeah because i feel like my head
is just very blank and then when i'm
like
because when i'm trying to think of like
a joke to make it sound funny i'm like i
don't know it's funny i've never heard
julia roast anyone yeah or make a joke
about anyone every dude yeah you're
accidentally funny
i just remember like thinking back on
all the jk party games that we try to
play and we try to be mean to people
like i [ __ ] can't do it like i can't
think of it roast me right now
yeah
i would say you're [ __ ] pale but i'm
yeah
i feel both feel the melanin deficiency
seriously for vitamin d people like that
is very important for your health
she goes i would say you're pale
she's like if i if you're going down i'm
going to with you
see that's a good person she didn't let
me swim or sink alone
she got it with me that's awesome yeah
they don't feel too bad i don't know
i don't know i don't like to think bad
of a person yeah i mean that's hot yeah
wasn't that funny baby i know baby's
laughing too
okay next one says
they tell you to take your time what
most people don't realize is that is
that bit of common courtesy shows that
you recognize that uh the other person
is a human being whose time and emotions
also have value many people are so
lacking in self-awareness and empathy
that they simply do not value other
people's time
i think about that a lot when i ask
someone to do something i try try to now
think like how fast do i need it because
the way that i speak to people they feel
a lot of pressure to please me instantly
so i have to make sure to be like oh you
have two days or or i don't need this
right now or get to this when you can or
because yeah but
i don't know if that's a good person
thing if you don't i think maybe you
just don't
well i guess realizing other people's
yeah because then i stress because i
know the opposite like i have received
the opposite of not being like someone
not being courteous to my time and the
way that they communicate it's like give
this to me now like i need this right
now yeah or it's just it's like holy
[ __ ] okay and like
it's just like you know that feeling of
like not being like oh my god i need to
drop everything to please this person
because of the way they're communicating
it's so cool is that usually a work
thing or just even in your personal life
you've had people that made you feel
like they demanded things from your time
in a personals um
i think i could
what comes to mind is a work thing
but it also bleeds into personal okay so
it has happened with
like the same person
in the personal aspect where it's like
holy [ __ ] like [ __ ] getting a text is
like give like gives me ptsd for that
person because i'm thinking like holy
[ __ ] i'm gonna have to drop everything
i'm doing right now and just like go
tend to what their needs are because
that's how urgent it seems
and yeah and then like once it's
communicated like hey like i really try
to do this thing i can't right now
because i got all this other stuff and
then and then that person doesn't
realize that that's how they're
communicating so they're like oh it's no
big deal just give it to me when you
have time and i'm like
you should have told me that
because the way it was written it was
like i need it right now and not like oh
[ __ ] yeah do you think though like do
you think cause you have a like a
regular job do you think that that kind
of a pressure of is that okay in the
workplace like do you or do you feel
like you would still wish that your
superiors or the people demanding stuff
from you would
let you know how much time you have
[Music]
i don't know because like i feel like
the producer that i work under we
communicate quite often yeah and i ask a
lot of questions too where i'll be like
okay so is this a priority or is this a
priority and then like how long does
like um when do you need it by you know
so like i'm always asking those
questions so i kind of like set myself
up for success that's good that's great
but yeah did that come out of um
experience though yeah i think so thank
you
i think so honestly because i i just
feel like how much time do i have
because i don't want to piss you off
yeah exactly but i i do feel like it
comes in both very personal and work
whether um you know like you tell people
like hey it's okay you know take your
time kind of thing because like i see it
in like both sides where like people are
like freaking out right and i feel that
i'm like okay you're fine we're okay
everything's good it's just like just do
what you need to do and then like we'll
we can figure it out from there yeah
yeah and i feel like that's always
helpful because it's just like when
someone is panicking it does no one any
good
yeah
the result is probably not going to be
yeah what you wanted anyway yeah that's
a good point like telling someone when
you realize like that they're trying to
tend to what you're asking for
immediately because i notice i try to do
that like with casey for example because
he's so good about
being like if i mention something
especially right now that i'm pregnant
it's like oh man i'm kind of craving a
donut he's like i'm gonna go get a donut
right now even though i know he's
working on a deadline and he's like
really busy
and i'm like oh no no no it's okay thank
you though i really appreciate that or
if i do have a request for something
then i'll tell him like oh just whenever
you have time it's not like don't rush
like it's okay because he will like drop
everything and just go get it that's the
perk of being pregnant
i feel like a little bit though like you
should let him have to be the role of
like the husband that has to hurry up
and go get dance like i know we need to
live through it a little bit we're
carrying a whole
i'm sorry who's putting all their
efforts into growing yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
julia since like you're still working in
production yeah i should poach you for
g4 oh my god
that would be so funny what did i do
like producer oh my gosh
camera stuff again
okay i mean yeah you're so good at it
yeah i don't know what you're doing now
but you're really good i'm just a
coordinator just a question dude that
would be so much fun to have you back on
set
i should talk to them
i would i would probably have those
moments and be like tina
i basically do the same thing that i did
in jk party
yeah i know that's why like i could just
imagine i'd be like gina's like i don't
know if i want to work for you actually
[Laughter]
okay next one
they bring their shopping cart to the
cart return when they're done with it
thank you i told you nicki was a bad
person because she does not [ __ ] take
her cart back what did she put it she
does it no yeah she said sometimes she
does and sometimes she doesn't but she's
like yeah i don't have to all the time
right i could just like pop it up on the
little hill like the little one do it
i'll do it like
80 to 95 of the time why 80 that's kind
of low yeah well it's a it's higher than
[ __ ] seventy [ __ ]
you should make sure eighty percent of
the time is not one hundred percent of
the time so
i guess i'm being generous with how many
to i don't know i'm not very exact so
what do you think is the other two out
of ten she only does is she only leaves
it out at shitty places if there's like
a storm outside she'll let these [ __ ]
stop go collect it
yeah let them come get it in the
lightning yeah okay
now the times that i would leave it is
like for example um i don't know the
only thing i can think of right now is
[ __ ] years ago when isaac was a
toddler and i have to like put him in
the [ __ ] car seat oh yeah i don't
want to leave if you have a baby then
[ __ ] the car
i'm like okay let me just [ __ ] it really
quick okay sorry i gotta go no because
there's been instances of people
worrying about the card or something
that a baby gets [ __ ] stolen oh my
gosh oh
never leave your baby unattended in a
parking lot they will steal your [ __ ]
baby in a parking lot okay now okay okay
so now i understand okay so it's okay
[ __ ] the shopping cart yeah don't ever
like turn your back i never thought
about that possibility yeah
again kids are ruining [ __ ]
technicians yeah
i feel like i'm the type of person that
if i were to return the car i would
return it to the furthest place on
accident like i wouldn't see the one
honestly
i honestly won't see the one that is
like three feet away from me
[Applause]
[Music]
and then like my friends would be like
yeah you didn't see it i'm like no
otherwise i would have done
at least you did it still yeah yeah
that's nice yeah that's true okay next
one
when they are given a chance to quietly
talk bad about someone they say
something good instead
that's why someone talking [ __ ] about
their ex can be a bit of a red flag i
understand that feelings about
relationships are difficult but i know
that if someone speaks positively or at
least in a neutral manner about their ex
i trust them a lot more
immediately that goes for job interviews
too like if you like even if you want to
talk [ __ ] about your last boss or
something you can never ever but if
you're with your close friends you could
talk [ __ ] about it
however i've met people before where
they're like oh no i don't talk about
anyone i'm like oh you're a really good
person it turns out they're not a good
person they just hide it very well oh
[ __ ]
yeah they need an hour why would they do
that
to like to see him off as a good person
oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah cause that's one of the most common
things like oh if i never talk [ __ ]
about anyone then they'll think that i'm
a good person but it turns out oh really
i guess that could be a manipulation
technique yeah
do you if you hear someone kind of
talking [ __ ] do you just instantly think
they're a bad person or do you think
like oh i wonder what happened with them
like that sounds bad or uh more of the
latter because i feel like there's
always like two sides to a story right
and so it's just like well if this
person is talking poorly about another
person there must be a legitimate reason
why
that's how i am too you know
it turns out that sometimes that person
is [ __ ] talking you too and everyone
like every [ __ ] which way like so
you're just like oh [ __ ] this person's
just spreading [ __ ] constantly yeah
that's hard but i usually just think oh
that's interesting like what happened
yeah and then i get burned by that same
person i'm like well [ __ ] for sure i
feel like i would it depends on exactly
what they're saying too yeah because
sometimes they could just be like oh
yeah they were crazy or like oh yeah
they did like they treated me this way
or what i don't know who whatever the
point is like it depends like how
they're saying like what this is how
revealing the information is to like is
how deeply personal like i'm like oh
wait maybe i maybe i shouldn't know that
yeah like you're especially the degree
of separation from the person it's like
wait this is [ __ ] weird why would you
share something that personal with me
like that's crazy that you would say
that that seems kind of like i think one
of the worst people that i've ever met i
should have
caught it in the beginning because yeah
it was like a group of creators and then
he outed that person's sexual
orientation immediately whoa he's like
oh he didn't hear from me sorry and i'm
like
i don't [ __ ] because nobody even public
knows it yeah and i was like you just
outed i just met you like 10 minutes ago
dude yeah crazy oh my god it's just like
that one situation i forgot with like
that survivor host
uh it was like it was on the show
survivors i didn't i don't know i don't
i i remember like watching it somewhere
i don't remember but it was like not too
long ago where on the show survivor like
you have like it's basically like you
have to be the i think the last one
standing i think i don't watch the show
i just saw the clip but basically if
you're on the chopping block you have to
present your argument as to why you
should stay
and so um one of the contestants was
saying that like oh yeah i bet you guys
didn't know that that this person is
transgender like he's a liar oh and it
was just like my god and like nobody
knew about it but him and he just like
completely outed him
and then like the host i forgot who the
host was but props to him though like he
handled it very well and he was like so
you're basically saying that
transgender people are liars like you're
basically saying that like they're
intentionally trying to lie to you so
they kicked that guy out from here
[Music]
like someone that would try to use
something like that against another
person that's instant yeah yeah yeah and
it sucks too because that guy felt
comfortable enough with that contestant
to share that piece of information with
them and he just totally used it as
a competition i'm like wow yeah okay bro
yeah yeah i think that's a huge red flag
when they're willing to just randomly
tell you about someone that's very
clearly obvious personal really
traumatizing stuff oh yeah
that [ __ ] i guess we have to be more
cognizant of it because i think everyone
just like or a lot of people and
sometimes including myself love some tea
oh yeah but 100 you have to like balance
that because like yeah or then you have
to remember like oh should i trust this
person myself
but i forget because i'm just like oh
they're giving me the teeth like we're
going to be friends now and then you
know sometimes get burned what do i
think about is um
like for the most part
like i try to think about like well
if i
tell
you something private about someone else
what are you gonna think of me and like
how how are you going to trust me and
also like how do i know that
that won't end up happening to me
so then for me i always think of like
nah [ __ ] that never i'm not doing that
[ __ ] like yeah i don't wanna yeah cause
you kept a secret from me about someone
else for like forever yeah yeah you and
i are super close friends and that's
kind of cool we both did actually yeah
i'm like guys come on
six years to be in the inner circle yeah
yeah and that's because for me it's like
that's not my secret to tell yeah that's
not myself there's some things where i'm
just like yeah i'll never like
it's really not my place i'll never
[ __ ] say that [ __ ] to anyone else but
yeah yeah exactly okay next one they
make casual excuses to do good deeds
picking you up from the airport oh i was
on my way buying you a beer i
accidentally ordered two where is this
person where are you cute do you know
how many of these people i only see them
on like tv shows yeah this is some sick
[ __ ] you actually casually goes to
the airport yeah i've never seen anyone
do that before it's always like yeah
i'll help you but i've never seen them
make an excuse or maybe we just did
ourselves yeah like maybe we're just
like oh well well they said they bought
two beers oh like by accident i don't
know like maybe we just won't even pick
up on it who knows but the rest of what
they wrote is
um like oh helping you move i need the
workout now i don't have to go to the
gym later anyone who does a favor sounds
nice yeah anyone who does a favor for
you and then acts like you're doing them
a favor or brushes the favor off as
nothing is a person who is doing the
good deed for the sake of it and not for
the praise or clout they receive yeah
these are the best kinds of people it's
cute i remember i was reading an article
about or like a story about um this man
who
helped out a homeless person that was
just selling something that's completely
just [ __ ]
nothing you know and then his son asked
him like why didn't you just give him
the money why why don't why did you buy
something instead he's like well because
it's charity disguised as dignity this
is how i see you know
i didn't even think of that because like
a lot of times even like with the ladies
come around with the flowers and stuff
i'm like i don't want to take it because
i feel like then you could still sell it
so i'm giving you the opportunity to
make more money by not taking your
inventory but i could see how
the dignity part might not be there if
they're not actually making a
transaction so that's that's probably
good to know yeah
yeah i like that yeah i don't have a lot
of people in my life that do that though
let me hear let me do this for you yeah
imagine it's like gina thanks for
delivering my baby i was just in the
area
do you have people in your life that's
or i i feel like you're the person maybe
that one yeah
yeah
you're so helpful this is julia to the
team
i guess maybe i mean i think you're just
like no don't worry about it it's fine
yeah i feel like the one common story
that i hear the most amongst the editors
is when we did the spartan race one time
and like i know that i was like hanging
out with them like for like the first
half of it but then when i looked at the
time i was like oh [ __ ] i gotta book it
because i got to pick up sandwiches for
these people
yeah yeah so like
so like i i hear them talk about it all
the [ __ ] time and i forget that i did
that [ __ ] yeah because then you're like
oh sorry i gotta ditch you guys because
i gotta go get sandwiches and then they
finish the race and i just remember like
seeing i think nelson and byron at the
finishing line they're like oh you
finished i was like yeah i gotta go get
sandwiches i totally forgot because that
was just on my mind but then when they
tell me the story i was like i did this
yeah imagine you showing up the subway
just covered in mud yeah
four sandwiches please sir yeah yeah
yeah yeah
that's awesome
all right so before we go to the next
one
quick sponsor break i'll see you in a
second
or we'll see a second
buy everything hey guys did you know
that referring a friend on fanduel
sportsbook could be your ticket to super
bowl 56 that's right when you refer a
friend on fanduel sportsbook in
partnership with valley forge you'll be
entered for a chance to win an
all-expenses paid trip to the super bowl
56 for two people that's you and a
friend so you don't have to go there and
be alone you could have a friend there
with you or you know your grandma your
mom whoever's in your life uh don't miss
fanduel's biggest referral friend offer
ever all you have to do is share your
exclusive referral link right from the
sportsbook app and once your friend
places any bet of ten dollars or more
you both get fifty dollars and you will
be entered into the super bowl
sweepstakes if you or a friend has been
thinking about joining fanduel now is
the perfect time to give it a shot i
mean ten dollars to get fifty dollars
that is a bet in your favor
i love fanduel it's super easy to use
app of all the apps they always have
great offers and you get paid in as
little as two hours when you win so last
time i won i was like hell yeah and then
i'm like when do i get to spend that and
it just came like almost instantly like
well like i didn't have to wait very
long so if you're new to fanduel you can
also sign up with a promo code big mood
to get your first bet risk free up to
one thousand dollars that's a lot of
doll hairs that's promo code big mood
see for yourself why fanduel is
america's number one sports book just
download the fanduel sportsbook app and
refer a friend for your chance to win a
trip to super bowl 56 for two don't
forget to use code big mood
b-i-g-m-o-o-d disclaimer 21 plus and
present in arizona colorado connecticut
iowa illinois indiana michigan new
jersey pennsylvania tennessee virginia
or west virginia referred players must
wager ten dollars or more within 28 days
after signing up bonus issued a site
credit and is not withdrawal and expires
after seven days restrictions apply see
terms at sportsbook.fanduel.com no
purchase necessary for the super bowl
ticket promotion super bowl promotion
closes on january 9th 2022 gambling
problem call 1-800 next step or text
next step to 53342 for arizona
chat in 1-888-789-7777
1-800-522-4700 in colorado 1-800 vets
off in iowa 1 809 with it in indiana 1
800 gambler in michigan new jersey
pennsylvania illinois virginia in
tennessee red line 1-800-889-9789
for tennessee or visit
www.1800gambler.net in west virginia we
deserve to know what we're putting in
our bodies and why especially when it
comes to something we take every day
now let's talk about ritual rituals
essential for women 18 and over
multivitamin was formulated by
exhaustive research to help fill
nutrient gaps in the diets of women ages
18 and over it is formulated with
nutrients to help support brain health
bone health blood health and provide
antioxidant support did you guys know
that over 97 percent of women aged 19 to
50 are not getting enough vitamin d from
their diets and 95 are not getting the
recommended daily intake of key omega-3s
but you don't have to worry when you
take rituals essential for women 18 and
over multivitamin because they invested
in a gold standard university-led
clinical trial to prove the impact of
essential for women 18 and over
multivitamin the results it was shown to
increase vitamin d levels by 43
and omega-3 dha levels by 41 in 12 weeks
the clinical study was also published in
leading scientific journal frontiers in
nutrition which is a big deal but ritual
is also committed to third-party testing
from usp and non-gmo project it's
traceable and vegan-friendly ingredients
and always clear communication no shady
stuff you guys ritual is my absolute
favorite i've been taking the prenatal
for over a year and a half now i
comparing it to other prenatal vitamins
that i've had in the past i absolutely
love ritual because i genuinely feel my
body absorbing these nutrients i don't
get those nasty vitamin burps that you
get with other other vitamins ritual it
just feels so clean and also it's so
aesthetically cute because they're they
come in these cute little capsules
they're all gold i absolutely love it
highly recommend ritual so ritual is
offering our listeners 10 off during
your first three months visit ritual.com
big mood and turn healthy habits into a
ritual that's 10 off ritual.com
big mood don't forget go to ritual.com
big mood for 10
off and we're back did you buy it did
you do it
next one
they ignore things like when you
accidentally fart or spit while talking
so you don't feel embarrassed i do yeah
for sure yeah i try to ignore it
like it unless i know the person that
i'm like
yeah that's true you [ __ ] farted i
know you did
i heard it
that's funny
you know
all right go ahead
broccoli says good people
such good you're so nice
okay yeah so
i i feel weird because i was the one who
did this but it reminds me of this one
time where um a friend
was
i was driving my car and we went
somewhere and she was sitting in my
passenger seat is this me
no there's no one no one here okay um
and she was sitting in my passenger seat
and she was like
as i dropped her off at home she's
leaving and she's like oh man like i'm
on my period oh my god i hope i didn't
stain anything or anything and i'll just
and i look and there was a stain but i
was just like oh no you're good like no
nothing there and then she couldn't see
it because it was kind of dark seats oh
but um but you could see like just like
a dark circle or something i know i
could see like the blood like it was
actually like yeah like it definitely
leaked through
oh i remember so i dropped her off she
texts me and she tells me oh my god i
bled through like i hope i didn't like
getting like she noticed on her pants
and then i told her like oh no my car is
good like and you're and they're just
like mopping up
hydrogen peroxide
yeah that's nice that's why i said it's
kind of weird because i did that but
like that's kind of what that reminds me
of it's just like why embarrass them
like why why make them feel like
horrible whatever it's like no big deal
[ __ ] clean it like i'm a woman i know
like it's fine yeah i like i like people
who tell you like hey you have a little
something over here yeah yeah you know i
can come over here yeah i always have to
tell someone just and but it's for me
though because i can't tell
i can't stand looking at it you know i
like how all your good deeds are just
motivated by you like you're she's a
good person yeah
i feel like there is no issue to point
out anything if it's like your close
friend yeah because then that's just
like a fun funny fun moments right and
i'm sure that if you guys are like close
enough then it's just like oh yeah
thanks for getting my back right but
then if it's like somebody you don't
really interact with the most of the
time you're just like what do i do
but you know like if there's a stranger
a girl in the bathroom at a bar you're
gonna tell her she's got toilet paper
for sure there's a certain time but if
it's sometimes like if it's an old man
and like his toupee's a little crooked
like i'm not going to say anything you
know because i feel kind of bad for him
that's true it depends on the level of
like what it is yeah like if i pity them
i usually like
don't want to tell them because i feel
like it'll hurt them or they're not
strong enough to realize that something
embarrassing is happening
but i'm like nah you're fine just get
the [ __ ] off your face like you know
yeah with most people yeah it's all
about like preserving their
own
is it dignity like you don't want them
to be embarrassed what is that i guess i
mean like if it's for the toupee right
it's like you know that it's a toupee
and you know that this person is
self-conscious about their hair because
they have a toupee so you don't really
want to comment on that yeah i think
it's kind of one of those awareness i
feel like i remember when i was go go
dancing one night and this guy came up
to me he's like
i'm like hey what's up he goes um i just
want to let you know one of your lips is
hanging out
you were you're a good person
your vagina was hanging on you couldn't
feel that no that he could that he told
him because i have like straps
everywhere efficiently
and i was like thank you like you're
good whoever that guy is i hope
someone's touching your pee pee right
now yeah you deserve it he earned pee
pee touching points yeah
helping you stuff your vagina lip back
in your pants yeah somewhere out there
he's telling a story like this one good
answer i had to tell her her lip was
hanging out
he's commenting that was me
those moments for sure you need to tell
somebody yeah i think there's a like
sometimes like if you don't tell them
it's almost like worse because then they
get embarrassed in front of more people
yeah like yeah it depends it's kind of
shitty if you don't say anything yeah at
that point it's like now you're you're a
bad person because you don't want to be
the bad person you don't want to tell
them or embarrass them yeah it's more
about you not wanting to say something
i remember seeing a girl at the beach
and this wave just like hit her but like
she was fine she was fine but when when
the waves passed she just one of her
boobs was hanging out and i was like oh
[ __ ] i gotta get to her so i try to get
her and be like yo you're your boob and
she's like oh [ __ ] so she like went and
she like scooped it in and i was like
they're good
yeah you don't want it
to me was this me
no no it was completely because i
remember something similar happening in
tulum
i was like oh [ __ ]
i've never had that problem because my
boobs don't go anywhere they're flat but
i do remember you though julia in tulum
a wave did knock me down
but nothing had nothing came out no no
but i got it i gotta shine the light on
you shine the spotlight on julian how
good of a person she is because
i think i even have this on video i
would think i was vlogging
no you you were vlogging with a gopro
yeah oh yeah
and so the part that i'm like julia's
such a good person is because like i
fell i was fine but she was so quick and
attentive to like pull me up yeah but
then at that moment like your like the
helpfulness was kind of like
preventing me from getting up
i was like no it's okay julian it's okay
it's okay i got i got it no but like
just your intention though and like how
passionate you were about like helping
me i was like you're such a good person
julia you don't know how many [ __ ]
videos i've seen of people on the beach
once they fall they get carried by the
tide like
no other dude like they just go with it
and then like people try to catch him
but they miss him and i'm like bro bro
it's like i cannot let this go drift off
in front of my eyes yeah that rib time
you get sucked into that yeah that's
just so funny though
okay next one
they don't brag others brag for them
could be a green yeah
okay but also like are we like never
allowed to be proud of ourselves
i think bragging is a specific kind of
form of communication
i think it's more like
yeah so like the other day like everyone
knows has to know how your [ __ ] doesn't
stink all the time right yeah i think
there's a right way to do it like guys
can i tell you something i'm really
proud of really yeah yeah
instead of just like
i'm gonna
i got this ring
i know you're going to do that when you
get a ring though
yeah of course
you're going to be on g4 like so guys
today
microphone
i mean even that like that's kind of
funny it's like yeah it's like
light-hearted but there's like a really
shitty way to brag though yeah like
maybe like i got into an argument with
someone not too long ago they were like
why do people feel the need to tell
others how much they make or something
like that you know and i was like
well do you think it's like that they're
bragging or that they're proud of the
fact that they got to a certain level of
income like not that that's their whole
value or anything but like it's an
accomplishment yeah so i guess there's
maybe i don't know some people don't
like
bragging
and but sometimes maybe it's not always
bragging that's like it's difficult to
say when it's
because like say if i met someone and i
was like yeah and then now i have like
this many streams of income and i can
make this much and i'm like so proud of
myself you know i was like super [ __ ]
poor or whatever then that per if that
person comes back at me like why do
people feel the need to tell you how
much they make and then i'm just like
i mean why why is that why is that bad i
don't know i'm like sharing something
that i'm proud of i think it's the way
that you do it because for like for
example like some girls just talking to
you like yeah you know it's whatever
like i go to celebrity parties all the
time you know i always get invited to
these things and like
always i'm friends with brad pitt yeah
yeah or like oh i like your purse so i
got it like the super expensive one the
other one have you heard of the brand
that's better than yours you know yeah
yeah it's a very certain type of they're
speaking down to you yeah yeah there's a
horse two different stories that have
both of both of your guys's examples so
one is um when i was working at a
restaurant i don't think i've ever made
so much money in my life yeah that like
i was just so excited and i had no
intentions
do you see this like i can't believe
this right and like i understand that
like she was probably like not in a good
place at the time i should have just
been a little bit more mindful at least
personally for me right because she was
like can you not flaunt your money to me
please like it's kind of like putting me
down right like so she was able to
communicate to me and because of that i
was like oh [ __ ] this is not like the
right thing to do it's not exciting for
you it's not yours yeah exactly so like
for me i was just like oh [ __ ] okay yeah
yeah i'm really sorry right and so that
was the other one the other one was also
at the restaurant and i remember i was
gifted a watch for my aunt and uncle it
was like a michael kors watch right
and
i had this co-worker that like
always bought like brand name stuff or
like um invest into it right which is
like you know not a bad thing because i
think that you know whatever money you
put into it is worth right
and so she was just showing me he's like
yeah you know i just got this watch like
it was so new and like it's like really
hard to get and it looked like a
knockoff michael kors watch but i didn't
know how else to tell her be like oh
yeah i have that watch right and then
she was like oh yeah i was like yeah
like let's compare so then i compared it
you can tell mine was the real [ __ ] and
hers was fake and then the next day i
never saw her wear it ever again and i
was like
oh that was not intentional but also at
the same time oh by the way your michael
kors watch his
we face pretty solid
mine i don't think if i'm doing that
i don't know yours kind of looks cheap i
don't know yeah exactly but like yeah
she was definitely like bragging about
her watch and [ __ ] i was like i mean
like look great for you you feel happy
for it but then like if you're trying to
say it's a real deal like
sorry oh that's so funny
i had embarrassing an accidental moment
like that actually a week or two ago
i was at an engagement party right and
her ring was beautiful like so beautiful
and she's like i got it from i mean he
got it from me from this site called um
something earth like uh brilliant
brilliant earth or whatever and i was
like i heard that name is the instagram
ad once yeah i always see it oh like
their ads there's always so i was like i
heard that name before and i remember it
was something that i liked because i
liked um like i don't i don't care much
for real diamonds i like like moist and
nights i like uh lab grown more like
eco-friendly yeah yeah and i was like oh
i remember that name well it's the site
that does oh what was it it's it's i
don't think it's a moist night one right
and then this guy comes up he goes did
you just call her ring a moistenite ring
that's kind of rude i was like no no no
no no not at all i'm just saying like
i'm trying to figure out what that was
yeah yeah what was that known for and
she's like oh it's lab grown once i'm
like there you go the lab grown ones i'm
like not calling her a moistnite ring
yeah like calling even a moistened ring
is [ __ ] nice yeah
he said something like are you saying
that she can't afford a real diamond i
was like no like what the hell first of
all who are
mean to say that it was like a fake
diamond you know and she's like no it's
a lab grown i'm like there you go that's
the reason why i've heard of that
because i wanted one of those mm-hmm
yeah that's something
jesus christ man he comes in all crowded
yeah trying to it's the guy that would
buy it though
not her she's not going to buy her oh
true
you're not offending her
maybe it was like the best man or
something or no wait that doesn't make
sense no i don't know guys don't give a
[ __ ] he popped up i don't know where i
don't even know where the hell he came
from
like what the [ __ ] man
all right next one they are good to
animals and customer service staff
especially when they are agitated
well yeah duh i mean we don't like
animal killers
or they don't have to be killers but
they could just be like i don't care
about this animal's life you know what i
mean being neglectful
yeah do you care about my person because
i i don't care that much about factory
farming
my bad person factory farming yeah
what's that because like you know vegans
are like so concerned about the welfare
of animals that they're only vegan not
because they don't like the taste of me
but because they don't like how they're
treated right but i like knowingly still
consume meat am i a bad person because
of that i don't know i struggle with
that same simple question because i'm
like i have seen the videos and i have
heard how they're treated especially
when it comes to like milk and like the
whole thing with pills
yeah and i'm like oh
but i still consume it yeah i'm the same
way i feel like this one's a little
hypocritical because it's like yeah i'll
treat a dog in anything cute amazingly
and i'll make sure that they have a soft
little bed
and then i'll eat a steak so i don't
know it's a little hypocritical uh i
don't i don't know like i
there are some things like if i can
avoid it i do
you know like i i think i learned
somewhere that those ostrich skin bags
from designer stuff yeah those ostrich
bumps like yeah it's from them yanking
out the feathers i was like well i'm
never getting one of those so i'll do
something like that i don't even like
the way it looks they're alive or dead
alive because if they're dead
when they're alive they pluck when
they're alive like down feather stuff
like they're alive still oh [ __ ] they
are why
i don't know
i mean i haven't done all the research
okay this is like a wrap yeah yeah
this is a [ __ ] rabbit hole yeah so i
think an effort but it is hard still
yeah yeah eating food and stuff yeah
like i think for example like okay that
whole side of the animal thing it's like
okay let's set that aside okay that's
big to unpack but i think like i think
more like for example you see
some
uh [ __ ] i don't know straight dog on
the street i'm trying to think of like a
not so cute animal like
like a snake possum that's kind of
injured on the side of the wood still
alive what about this what would you do
oh injured it's roadkill come on
see
okay
what about this okay when i first moved
back to texas there was a there was like
a period of time when there was like a
bunch of beetles that would come out
right like these big huge black beetles
like the ones you would see like they're
kind of like green the ones that i like
they're really exciting oh yeah
but they're like huge they're like you
know like a couple inches wide and long
real big and then for some reason there
were so many of them out and for some
reason they don't know how to walk and
they kept falling on their back so there
would be i would take my dogs for a walk
and there would be so many beetles just
like oh my god like they can't [ __ ]
roll over and my dogs would try to tie
no my dogs would try to like attack them
and i would keep my dog from attacking
the beetles and i would like [ __ ]
kick it over so i could walk like keep
going because so many of them would be
just on their [ __ ] back all these
little beetles and i'm like they're
totally pointless they're probably gonna
get run over by a car but like i would
like to flip it over and let it go on
its journey imagine just like i hold my
dogs back and then i just stomp on it
dude i'm so inconsistent when it comes
to insects yeah because sometimes
i'll be like oh let's just like try to
capture it and release it but then other
times i'm like it
like the same [ __ ] insect i'm like
it's [ __ ] disgusting just kill it
just get it if it's a spider 10 out of
10 i want it dead if you if it has more
than eight legs i want it dead like
spiders or the children yeah because
spiders can chill with something
yes these are scary those can get people
scared oh i cannot stand those no like
the june bug like one of them came
inside the house
those are cute and i was well see i grew
up like i the very first time i saw this
bug
it was called a stink bug or brown brown
one i don't remember but a jumbo glitter
shape's like brown isn't it yeah it's
brown it's small yeah diamonds i don't
know but whatever this bug is when i
very first saw it
kids this is elementary school so they
all said like if you kill it it's gonna
stink and it's going to be so gross and
you don't want to ever kill this bug you
always want to just like shoo it away or
whatever
and then casey was like well no this
one's a june bug like it won't do that
so then i'm like kill it
oh my god yeah the june bugs i don't get
i feel like if it's going to hurt me i
have to kill it yes like mosquitoes yeah
okay
[Applause]
i hate mosquitoes
yeah
i know the woman i see them like [ __ ]
virus carriers yeah especially yeah
especially now that i'm pregnant and
i've been getting mosquito bites yeah
i'm like a little bit paranoid creepy
i'm scared i'm i'm like seriously so
like
initially i thought crane flies were
mosquitoes because they look exactly
like this but they're just big right and
i used to be like scared of them and i
remember my mom she'll catch him with a
hat her hand and like i'll be like such
a little [ __ ] she'll be like
wait are you biting her what's happening
no no no no no
they don't crane flies
they actually eat mosquitoes and when i
learned that like you are my [ __ ]
friend yeah i can't believe i was scared
of you i'm letting you never kill you i
didn't know that in my 32 years of my
life spiders 32 yeah spiders too they
kill all the bugs
i don't know if they do or not but i
know black widows can bite me yeah
and then there's like the brown widow
too yeah see i don't know insects are
tricky that's why i'm like i don't know
if i really fall into this category
because i own one of those bug zappers
so i'm like
i don't know am i a bad person because
yeah because you're just
zap zapping the [ __ ] out of all kinds of
insects
alright so
that's our episode you guys hope you
learned some stuff i learned that we are
all such great people yes they're super
good
i hope you you were introspective with
your own self and if you realize that
you're the opposite of this i hope you
change your ways and become a better
person put the shopping cart back limo
she said she doesn't know
okay she doesn't know she doesn't know
we're good unless you have a baby then i
get it yeah and thanks so much to julia
for joining thanks for having me make
sure to check out her ig it's in the
description
and what else uh maybe my youtube but um
also check out stat boost which is the
clothing company that my boyfriend and i
work on
that's not our slogan but i mean that's
part of the mission statement nice thank
you and make sure to check out our
sponsors to support the show and like us
write us five stars not ten five or
actually ten if you can
and we love you see you next time
[Music]
you